salut aujourd'hui je vais pas faire
cette vidéo non je vais plutôt la sphère
du demain mais demain j'en ai déjà il
après l'année prochaine c'est matin je
me suis réveillé je vous avoue j'avais
la flemme de faire cette vidéo met
vraiment j'aurais tellement aimé pour
reporter ce moment j'avais envie de
procrastiner procrastine court terme on
a un petit peu rigolo qui veut dire
remettre au lendemain repousser un petit
peu le moment c'est se mettre devant
leur ordinateur pour travailler et
s'apercevoir au bout d'une demi heure
qu'on est sur facebook
en fait on actualise la timeline
heureusement j'ai des astuces pour vous
empêcher de procrastiner et pouvoir vous
améliorez vous automotive et c'est
d'ailleurs une des demandes que vous
aviez fait durant le live sur périscope
c'est cyril qui avait demandé première
étape il faut être organisé dans sa tête
et sur le papier je vous présente donc
le super héros celui qui prend la
procrastination qu'il a tort et qui la
gère tout dolist karine taux de l'is est
un très bon moyen pour identifier tout
ce qu'on a à faire voir s'organiser le
poser sur le papier et identifier les
choses qui sont urgentes qui sont
affaire qui sont reportables ou pas je
suis un amoureux des to do list si vous
voulez faire comme moi vous prenez des
fiches de bristol j'en ai du jaune j'en
ai des bleus et roses des verts quand
vous écrivez votre to do list pour
qu'elle soit encore plus motivante vous
pouvez la sous-catégorie zay si je dois
faire les cours je vais pas écrire faire
les courses trop compliqué je sais que
je vais leur poussée dans ma tous les
boulistes je marquais faire une liste de
courses aller au magasin faire les
courses
ranger les courses à chaque fois que je
vais réaliser une des étapes je vais
pouvoir la barre et à chaque fois que
vous barrer une étape vous libérer un
petit stock d'endorphines que vous avez
quand vous mangez du chocolat quand vous
faites du sport quand vous avez un
orgasme quand vous avez un like sur
facebook si il ya des études qui ont été
faites là dessus pas tout de lui c'est
important c'est essentiel fall a fait
pour être efficace et ne pas progresser
il faut aussi savoir dire non non non il
faut savoir refuser certains projets
certaines choses que vous n'avez pas
envie de faire il faut savoir dire non
ça c'est non j'ai pas envie de le faire
pourquoi parce que si vous dites oui par
gentillesse vous n'allez jamais le faire
ça va faire naître en vous un sentiment
de culpabilité devez vous sentir
coupable de ne pas faire ce truc sur
lequel vous engagez mais que de toute
manière depuis le départ vous n'aviez
pas envie de faire les amis je vous le
dis sachez dire obligé vous a bloqué
deux heures par semaine pour travailler
sur quelque chose qui vous fait vraiment
plaisir qui vous fait vraiment envie
vous le reconnaîtrez facilement c'est le
truc dont vous parlez depuis deux ou
trois ans et vous dit non mais un jour
je vais faire ça je comptais un moment
et ça c'est sûr je vais le faire je vais
travailler un peu là dessus c'est sûr
dans mille ans à peu près mais je le
ferai
le seul moyen de réaliser ce projet ce
truc qui vous tient à coeur
dans le choeur ses dessous c'est de vous
obliger à bloquer deux heures dans votre
semaine pour ça voulait bloquer et vous
allez pouvoir prendre un moment là
dessus et ça vous fera du bien à la tête
et ça vous fera du bien à l'inde autre
astuce en rack quand vous devez
travailler sur quelque chose qui n'est
pas en lien avec internet l'ordinateur
ou le téléphone couper le wifi ou
seraient pas tentés d'aller geek et
durant des heures pour rien et je peux
vous dire que je parle en connaissance
de cause offrez-vous des récompenses et
ne fait pas l inverse l'averse a fait
culpabiliser par exemple si je dois
faire quelque chose si je dois faire un
super tableau excel sur mon ordinateur
ça marche pas sur moi parce que j'aime
bien faire ça remet on a tendance à se
dire dans ces moments là allez je prends
un café je fais une petite pause de cinq
minutes et je me mets et quand vous avez
fini votre pause votre café que vous
n'avez toujours pas envie de vous y
mettre vous culpabilisez c'est un
sentiment désagréable
malheureusement c'est normal alors que
si vous faites l'inversé vous vous
octroyez des récompenses
j'aurai le bon sentiment en vous celui
de la réussite est de l'accomplissement
il suffit juste d'un verset quand
j'aurais fait ça je me ferais une pause
de cinq minutes je me prendrais un café
suivant la tâche à accomplir offrez-vous
des récompenses plus ou moins
importantes voilà quelques astuces qui
j'espère vous empêcheront de
procrastiner en tout cas vous aideront à
ne plus procrastiner et surtout vous
déculpabiliser merci à tous ceux qui
contribuent aux sous titres de ces
vidéos ça fait longtemps que je vous ai
pas remercier merci merci merci merci
beaucoup si vous êtes intéressés il
suffit juste de contribuer au sous titre
des vidéos qui sont passés en faisant ça
on peut créer de nouveaux sous titre on
peut corriger les fautes des sous titres
qui sont déjà en place ça permet quelque
chose de juste exceptionnel ça permet de
rendre toutes les vidéos accessibles aux
malentendants merci encore à tous ceux
qui prennent du temps pour le faire si
vous êtes parfois reconnus dans cette
vidéo je me mets encore une vidéo est là
ce coup ci je me mets faites le moi
savoir en mettant un petit pouce en
l'air n'oubliez pas de commenter je lis
tous vos commentaires vous pouvez aussi
vous abonner rendez vous demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mortal blog chat
ou peut-être bientôt je suis jeudis
vendredis et samedis en spectacle à
l'entrepôt théâtre si vous voulez venir
c'est cool et peut-être on fera une
vidéo après